good morning Han it's Tuesday so your
video last week about your life with
hodkin lymphoma reminded me of when you
were first diagnosed as you pointed out
cancer is not really a disease but a
category of diseases and for about a
week we knew you had something in the
category of cancer but not actually
which cancer you had was it another kind
of lymphoma or a metastatic cancer that
had spread to your lymph nodes we didn't
know and when you finally found out it
was honkin lymphoma it was a tremendous
encouragement like of all of the bad
news we could have gotten that was about
the best bad news and when you called me
to tell me the news one of the first
things you said was 5year survival rate
is 93% with treatment and about 6%
without treatment you were already
thinking of the people who can't get
access to treatment which as it turns
out is a lot of people so there's
inequitable access to Cancer Care
everywhere but most people who get
cancer live in low and middle- inome
countries where it can be really
difficult to access appropriate care
like just in Sierra Leone a relatively
small country over 200 people get hodkin
lymphoma every year and I think a lot
about one of them a child named mday
monser mday lived in sier Leon's rural
Kono district and his parents first
noticed a lump on the side of his neck
when he was about 6 years old and about
the same time he started to become much
more lethargic at first as often happens
he was incorrectly diagnosed with
tuberculosis because the clinics that
Monday visited didn't have the super
fast super accurate Gene expert tests
instead TB was still diagnosed via
symptoms and tuberculosis often causes
swollen or even ruptured lymph nodes and
so that's what it appeared to be but
treatment for TB didn't work for Monday
and so his parents kept taking him to
Healthcare centers and hospitals but
because there was no capacity for
Imaging no MRI machines no CT scanners
in 2015 not even x-ray machines Monday
couldn't get a diagnosis and this lump
just kept growing eventually it was so
big it made it difficult for him to
swallow and so he was losing weight and
this went on for 4 years finally when he
was 10 Monday was examined by a doctor
with Partners in Health who suspected
lymphoma and Mund traveled to the
capital city to get a biopsy where it
was found that indeed he had hodkin
lymphoma Mund was able to get pill based
chemotherapy in Freetown Sierra Leon
which shrunk his tumor but to get into
remission he needed IV chemotherapy
which for him meant traveling thousands
of miles to rwanda's bharo cancer
hospital and now Hank like you Monday is
in remission he's a great young artist
when I visited him in 2019 I got to see
his sketch of my favorite football
player Muhammad Salah but think of all
that had to go right for him to survive
he needed to be correctly diagnosed we
often hear that early diagnosis is
really important in Cancer Care but in
these circumstances early diagnosis is
basically impossible and then Monday
needed to be able to access treatment
which meant not just enough money for
the treatment itself but also to spend
months in a hotel hotel in the capitol
city and have transportation from that
hotel to the hospital when he was too
sick to walk but even that wasn't enough
to truly enter remission he needed to
travel thousands of miles to a dedicated
Cancer Center all of this would have
been impossible for Monday's family to
afford without support from Partners in
Health and so one thing that you often
hear is that Cancer Care in poor
countries isn't costeffective but one
Hank nobody ever questioned whether your
Cancer Care was coste effective because
you're you and you live where you live
and two hodkin lymphoma is actually
relatively inexpensive to treat provided
you have the systems and structures in
place to do appropriate Diagnostics and
treatment and in the years since Monday
was treated that's starting to happen in
Sierra Leon better Imaging machines
better access to chemotherapy soon
hopefully the first radiotherapy
available for cancer patients in the
country but it's only starting to happen
and the devastating truth is that most
people with honken lymphoma in a country
like Sierra Leon will die even though
they could have lived what you made
clear to me in that very first phone
call Hank is that the same cancer
affecting two different people in
different circumstances is not really
the same cancer if the standard of care
available to those two people is
different the outcomes will be different
as well Hank I'll see you on Friday